before like what's more attractive babe  can you please be quiet or shut them  i've said this i've said this on pretty  much i think i've said it pretty much  every podcast like girls like the guy  that's like if you're going off here and  like you're just tap and you'll be like  listen hey shut the club breath like and  you'll be and then you always be like  damn like you just don't put me in my  place it's not fun i don't like  okay so he's done something wrong right  you're snapping on him like you're going  like you're trying to be the alpha right  now like you're trying to wear the pants  right and he just told you hey listen  like he just shows you like you need to  shut up  but he showed you like in a way where  it's like damn like he put me in my  stay  place